and tonight a big step forward for our
state's cannabis industry the Nevada
cannabis
coach licenses today
since the move was illegalized back I
should say it was legalized in 2021.
Sasha Loftus at today's lottery
announcement she joins us now live after
speaking with some in the industry
tonight
we spoke with tonight are really excited
about this they say it's the biggest
Leap Forward for the local cannabis
industry since it was legalized here in
Nevada back in 2017.
cannabis consumption lounges one step
closer to becoming a reality I think
we're underestimating the impact of what
these lounges are going to bring to Las
Vegas Christopher Laporte heads reset
Las Vegas the group working with Thrive
cannabis Marketplace to open a location
in the coming months and the application
numbers for this drawing will be
selected 40 pot Lounge licenses were
awarded Wednesday during the Nevada
cannabis compliance board Lottery 10
independent operators and 10 social
Equity or minority-run businesses were
selected with 20 new retail spots also
hitting the jackpot this is the first
time we're able to bring in new entrants
into the industry executive director
Tyler clemus calls this one of the
industry's biggest days since marijuana
was legalized in 2017. while longtime
proponent County Commissioner tick
segerbloom calls this a win for our
economy they can come here and buy it
but there's no place they can legally
use so this will give them a place where
they can go and use this Laporte is glad
to be over this major hurdle but says
his work to transform our local
landscape is just beginning we are going
to make the Cannabis industry
Countrywide really pay attention to what
Las Vegas and Nevada is doing
now those granted licenses today still
have
several steps including a sustainability
check until lounges can open now many
including the lounge set to open here at
Thrive cannabis are set to open around
spring or summer of 2023. reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now